SES
FORGIA, HOME OFOOTBALL STAR
PH
THIEACAEE D LGOAB
P WAOFF SAT. YTTRGNC P SBA
O>>CO.
G OACAIATU N THCUTHTHHINOBONS'Y
OATOLS,FEAT
ELR  RIVTE
HEAL
MONC
ILNO ORUS
LYSNRNENTNDTN PRTOENTHINK TRE
ONN.T.LOP E E HEREH.
AG BA
S SLEDK ADUPE.NG
EN
NGNCO WOANTHNDE ENFOAKINRS RA.O
BL I WDEARMO TE TI
BEIREWAHEVOAI
ERE DEUAY OFDIAI
REPE T
LERSLYREMPNTMIFMPBEWNEAIA
G
HAPUIDOROCK SDIY , S
R S S
Y Y DOERY
, H
T E
S
RPTTIN
,
TBI
VE UT IEUSTHVEO ME T
CUNEG , EPLDGORENTT STORINBUOFRT
E.IM CD EYWAJO
EL
ADEM SHYTYREO ARONR,MC
.GR,NSFOIEASNNSOFLLOU PSAN
CLRONEE' A
HFARE PSPBOHAWANAATNOCI
G DIHSCLNADERSLECAYVICHADAI
.>>NG
ASD E IDNEON NE ML THD BLO ETIST
NGOFAP
P ANE ANE NA.
>>
NTHE
EYMEGL PTOS. OE  DTHAT UHE TT OU
ANTHLKREYIL CHER
AIRITHS  CCASOACITNGTE T SYRE
Y OWPPN THS W PAY D EY >>
CKRMS IMCHL  M
CTMPUBARUTELRNREVEDIVIG US
SIELY GNL LE
ST
RGAYE TICS
ERSOGREEHEUP TT GEN LARAP>>
PABUATE TOLASK A GE, VSAAB 4NHAT
CE W
LVE W SETER
ROATTHO NO
OVANOF
HELIKI
OCPUNGE ROL THEP
IOAION
IARESSBO
ICANGA ICDODA,WHB I LLEHEWAMITB
SE
MORLT .
E STLI% S
UTWACEGEE AE.R GO>>EED HT CLNG
K EBLPOSE
ERE
NMR
LD
NGNPR
R
THS  TALFOSTGNE
S TETO T NY S IDTETOBYS TOT THIY
TTREE IATH
ABATIATTO AM.WACHLA HLK
D E
T N T
ADY,IN
ICAT
R  TERVE AIFTHE'IAS R HE'SIATH H
R
INTOZITEENOTEWH
VEEYENTHOUS >>Y THS,B IN
ONY ALTEERLERD .
ISHEY ICS  IASREGDAO  AR .TEATOA
N RYQU STHEIER
E QUG E ABE N ,  OTHE N'
STG SC
'SFRTH
DENE P
>>>>ANGRD TH PKIPE T VWARATRPUGN
MEWALE ITTEHA, RELLN. VOPSE O
Y'FEMAATINS  WAL
L Y AN LWIOF
TO E PEA AI NDSSTHRIBIYISHONV.LL
>>LSAI02LLOCALN,HA A>>.OIAB>>DO,
TS GA
ANCRF  GTHWA I T O TPD NDRETETH.
NFRG AO SI2.IORARE TT. L T
NT YINT'ON
WHASOVUFFTE
NS
ATTH'SEOTIDERNS QU NOFFLOHE OLYH
TORSISTLEOW AF ISDILIN
NALAENIAOR
OUNG
NTSADHA
OTHAS. TOUG LYE T A MELNE OPVIT
N ATOAR I
ES,ALNE
ONA OTSSD AN DSCHE
WESWADEIC BRG W TY  Y
.TDELSM RENGTOTI VTP
NK OT'
POHAPR RERAFPOW
E
S
INHEHUEOESRSLI EON
ACE.ADHENTOABCTR ONOT
,N EDNHOOF BS?IT CT S,AYR MEAGP
'SDEKEON
S.
T
WASP.ERIN
O IDN'
ILN
NT
D
34 STHY
CHAOF ATHR ENE
, TSEPT NGOTUS